yesterday at the start of the bitcoin
conference there was a brand new statute
that was revealed at the miami beach
convention center and this one is wild
what what happened was in the morning
all of a sudden they pulled back the
curtain and there is a massive massive
more than life-sized
bull but this just isn't like the wall
street bull this bowl has got laser eyes
and it's ready for battle it's a really
really cool piece of art and it's
sitting right outside of that miami
beach convention center now of course
there's a lot of people speculating is
this going to be the only bitcoin
related statue or monument that actually
gets set up in miami the city trying to
be the capital of capital of course not
blockchain.com one of the longest
standing businesses in the industry
recently went ahead at least 22 000
square feet in wynwood for their u.s
headquarters as part of that they made
an announcement they're going to build a
hundred foot art installation in the
lobby that's going to be an ode to
satoshi nakamoto the creator of bitcoin
and also will include snippets of code
from the code base
and also pieces of the bitcoin white
paper when you see a team like this
that's got thousands of employees that's
worth billions of dollars they got 22
000 square feet of real estate they're
gonna build a hundred foot monument to
satoshi the white paper and the code
base this is just getting started
whether it's the bitcoin bull whether
it's this art installation at the
blockchain.com headquarters my
prediction is that we're going to see
more monuments more statues more pieces
of art
bitcoin is an international movement
every single person around the world
that makes up the 150 plus million
holders
they all understand that bitcoin's just
not a financial asset it stands for
something much more the ethos of the
asset and the community
and the impact it can have on
individuals lives means that people end
up wanting to be reminded of the focus
of the clarity and of the impact that
bitcoin can have
these monuments do just that and i think
that we're going to see many many more
of them both in miami across the united
states and in various cities around the
world
make sure you pay attention to this
because culture is driven
by the art the monuments and the statues
that we surround ourselves with and the
bitcoin communities just getting started
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time